>>Hello YouTubers. This is Peter Piot from
Davos. I'm the director of the U.N. program
on fighting AIDS in the world. AIDS has become
one of the make-or-break issues of our time
and without defeating it there's no way that
for example Africa will be able reach development,
and with 6000 people dying every single day
it's a major crisis, but the good news is
now we've got results ,and now that many countries
infections are going down, and two and a half
million people are in treatment, compared
to basically none six years ago. So the big
challenge now is gonna be to make sure that
we prevent HIV and that nobody becomes infected
and that we have an HIV-free generation and
that depends on all of us. Use a condom every
time, you know, you're not certain that, you
know, you're having sex with someone that's
not infected and also reduce number of partners,
and postpone your first sexual intercourse
when you're very young. So we can do it and
we can all work towards a world free of AIDS.